it's a beautiful day to be alive the
birds are chirping the sun's I'm
oh [ __ ] it's [ __ ] that time for you
[ __ ] uncle Joey showing up with
the [ __ ] [ __ ] the [ __ ] Richard
Pryor smoke me and lit himself on fire I
still got a little bit of that badge
left I got this [ __ ] that killed Steven
Hawkings I got everything I got the [ __ ]
Trump smoked before he talked to the
Russians you came at a good spot oh [ __ ]
listen to this I'm smoking some [ __ ]
fire today so hope your [ __ ] a
ready for uncle Joey you follow me cuz
if you're not it's gonna be a long
[ __ ] afternoon for you I got death
here today so I hope you jumped out of
the [ __ ] window and you told your
[ __ ] family I'll be back in ten
minutes uncle Joey's dropping knowledge
here
tip type Magoo like a [ __ ]
worked out had a meeting sent a thousand
emails I annoyed everybody I got this
[ __ ] the Jeff session smoked you don't
hear from that little [ __ ] no
more do you I sent him a little [ __ ]
butter some wheat and I dipped in my own
pee it's all over anyway uncle Joey he
is swinging dick the podcast of my main
man
TJ English is up the author one of my
favorite [ __ ] authors working today
you guys don't know I read when you go
to prison you learn how to [ __ ] read
and then yet you stick with it you know
man Reading Is Fundamental [ __ ]
anyway I got some tremendous weed today
I got this [ __ ] in the right container I
got this [ __ ] that killed Stephen
Hawking
oh my goodness good googly moogly you
know how we do it here on the [ __ ]
church never a dull moment and I got
this [ __ ] here this is the explosion of
death here you follow me we got three
different types of weed waiting there
from three different avenues pull up a
chair
we're family what the [ __ ] this ain't
[ __ ] Olive Garden [ __ ] we're
here this sparked Dan all-you-can-eat
pasta there's all you could sling dick
that's what we do but enough with the
chitter chatter you guys know if I don't
pull Joey already let's get down and
[ __ ] you came to get down you came to
get down what jump around let's finish
this bath to death look at this good to
the last drop [ __ ] Maxwell House I'm
talking about uncle Joey's [ __ ]
house
getting ready for my plane ride tonight
to the big [ __ ] Apple I'll be in
Nyack Wednesday night get ready to
[ __ ] hit people in head with bottles
it's all over every witness relocated
whoo [ __ ] it'll be there it's gonna
[ __ ] be deep and then we take our
journey to [ __ ] Albuquerque New
Mexico on the fifth and sixth I haven't
been there in [ __ ] years last time I
was there saw some [ __ ] anyway
doesn't matter and then then I go to
[ __ ] Columbus Ohio for fourth point
I'm just getting wine we're waiting for
Netflix so if you want me to have an F
Lee specialists tell them Joey down on
that place where the [ __ ] is uncle Joey
special and they'll give it to you yeah
I'm saying and that's it and that's that
the week is put together the two
podcasts the [ __ ] taped you got TJ
today and you got my man Calvin on
Wednesday morning but joy which would to
chitter-chatter
let's part you're right you're right I'm
sorry I got a little filled up there
I got a poker at that as usual these
things work it's a [ __ ] barbecue
thing fishes kebabs or as a pope they W
no I'm saying you got to be [ __ ]
expendable to run with uncle Joey I love
it when we get together in the
afternoons they have these little
[ __ ] take days you follow me
there's in life this is what it's all
about take a tase with the people that
you [ __ ] love usually if I was by
your house I'd show up with a [ __ ]
strudel but I'm gonna wait watchin
points it can't be no [ __ ] strudel
I'm saying anyway I love you guys with
all my heart I'm happy you showed up
it's Monday as usual member you showing
up with a hard dick and a spout whoever
wants [ __ ] juice you're right there
on the [ __ ] location cuz you ain't
got enough time to [ __ ] around today's
the day it starts whatever happened last
week happened last you who gives a [ __ ]
we can't bring it back its history I
[ __ ] up a lot last week but if there
was a [ __ ] it's this week that matters
it's what you're gonna do this week is
we're gonna look in the I know it's time
for you to suck my dick
I'll a Harvey you know I'm sorry cuz
you've had enough [ __ ]
you're gonna go pursue your career as a
[ __ ] Boogaloo dancer up down on in
79th on the midnight shift
bring it on [ __ ] home anyway that's it
and that's that Paulette the Bombadil
it's nice that we get together no
[ __ ] drama no [ __ ] Zam we have this
I'm with you you're with me and they
want to be what else why cuz was [ __ ]
throwing Heat we ain't [ __ ] around we
get up in the morning we salute the flag
with [ __ ] fire coming out of my dick
you follow me you don't need no steroids
you mean none pure reefer heart and ball
juice put together and it goes right to
your heart it helps it [ __ ] pump and
they can't stop you joy which one will
you today I'm listening I'm flying up
it's [ __ ] Monday I'm going to the Big
Apple tomorrow night I'm going to
[ __ ] PJ English's book release party
he invited me
respect he's a [ __ ] Savage that dude
don't forget amazon.com the corporation
holds a battle story you know why he
opened up the toys they Ronda Rousey
because now I'm coming with my [ __ ]
story [ __ ] you guys want a book I'm
gonna give you books plural anyway let's
get back to doing what we do best I love
this [ __ ] [ __ ] it one more for the
road little [ __ ] my fish show up and
do one but like a half a [ __ ] you people
I respect you how to show up and kill a
couple [ __ ] meals oh yeah oh yeah
another one [ __ ] that Sam I'm going I'm
getting ready get the [ __ ] out here I'm
gonna plain and [ __ ] a few hours I'm
gonna get on that plane tune the [ __ ] up
my balls are gonna be on fire like the
[ __ ] Swami I'm gonna be looking at
people with the [ __ ] you looking again I
got my phone I got the pad I got a
couple [ __ ] hope that hope is
downloaded
I got a few books to read I got a couple
notes to make but I'm [ __ ] focused on
there even though you think I'm [ __ ]
a box up a little high uncle Joey's
always there Troy what are you talking
about you [ __ ] hear beating I know I
know
pilot to Bombardier I'm a little [ __ ]
up I'm Sam
let's get a little closer
it's like looking to your [ __ ]
eyeballs I'm over here looking at you in
the Sun in your [ __ ] facing you know
I catch a foul ball and I'm saying
anyway well good everything's tremendous
our weigh-in tonight at Weight Watchers
hopefully I'll be down at 285 sling and
dick and I'm gonna drop it to 265 just
in case but Lester makes a comeback
neither one able to fly his sidekick
your mother [ __ ] didn't know and
enjoy them your [ __ ] flying side kick
anyway listen I don't know flying psycho
some [ __ ] witch I get whole few kicks
and I'm done for the afternoon my wife
put up a link
I'm Joey Diaz dotnet you got rash guards
now from the church represent so you can
have a patch on your [ __ ] geek and a
rash guard and you're closer to your
heart you follow me so everyday you
representing the church and a big [ __ ]
way
and that's it from you know how we do we
get together we smoke our reefer we
reminisce about the old days and that's
it then we go our own ways that's the
best thing about the [ __ ] periscope
you don't gonna hang out and we gotta
get rid of all Joey's he's an old man
yeah no no no I just show up with a
[ __ ] button we smoke and I abandon
ship
what do you think should we do one more
we already finished two canisters let's
finish this death look at this had this
cultivate way more we cultivate the gig
and Goodfellas feeling good looking good
Billy Ray I can't show up with these
[ __ ] eyes the parents will be looking
at you like Jong Kook Joey what the [ __ ]
but I went let's do one more Bowl I
respect you know why because I love you
I don't want people to say Joey shows up
he does a bowl man there you go
I'm working on my grip and I'm saying my
[ __ ] fingers [ __ ] up my head caught
in that [ __ ] fence that time when I
was trying to rob the bookie in 85
anyway don't man let's do another
[ __ ] hit and I said we'll get
together here and it goes their own way
my mama oil Tamala Tomas Eddie I mean
that's a lot they seek the ER and be
shown it's [ __ ] Monday I'm checking
in with you [ __ ] that's what
real men do on Monday you check in with
your peeps you put a [ __ ] glass of
water out you light a candle for the
[ __ ] soldiers that died before you to
convert to [ __ ] remind you that you
got to do your [ __ ] you follow me and
that's it because they know or that
didn't come I might they're lobbying I
said hey no your mama call it that if I
met them that awful sorry anyway you
know I love you [ __ ] oh yeah
little storm dear I'm an old man but
[ __ ] it I still got hard balls and I
show up every day with my uniform on and
that's the most important thing even if
you [ __ ] sweep for a living as long
as you're the best sweeper that's all
that matters and you do your job of
pride and you put your heart your balls
into it and [ __ ] what anybody else says
they can at the end of the day they get
all suck your dick when you have to
supermarket buying grocery anybody
they're able to yardstick nah nobody's
damn so tell them all to suck it they
can only hang out with the Joneses the
judges need to hang out with UG
anyway I'm down too [ __ ] long and a
half because of you [ __ ] but you
know a [ __ ] that's worked at the half
of the family I'm with you you're with
me that's it with a church boy until the
[ __ ] wheels fall off and that's it
our point to use from New York report
tears from my act and I will make this
[ __ ] weekend we don't take [ __ ] from
nobody where the church always happened
now you understand me we show up with
the head high [ __ ] heart in place and
your [ __ ] heart in your head if they
don't want to do it then they gotta get
on their knees because you're [ __ ]
steamrolling you understand me that's it
and that's that have a great day
tell them what a suck your dick and then
don't matter because at the end that's
you and the casket alone [ __ ] you take
him today and the rest on a week to the
[ __ ] hoop like Julius Erving when he
was a [ __ ] net I really get out of
here
I love you [ __ ] Stabler